ist das das aus für den klassischen
verbrenner das eu parlament hat
beschlossen der verkauf von neuwagen mit
verbrenner motor soll ab 2035 verboten
sein hersteller in der eu dürfen nur
noch autos und transporter auf den markt
bringen die keine klimaschädlichen
treibhausgase ausstoßen im ergebnis
würde die umsetzung dieser beschlüsse
das faktische aus für den verbrenner
motor ab der mitte des kommenden
jahrzehnts bedeuten und damit einen
verkaufsstopp für neue privat pkw und
leichte nutzfahrzeuge mit diesel oder
benzin antrieb ziel ist eine umstellung
auf elektromobilität
er ist aber dass es aus des verbrechers
besiegelt so schnell geht es natürlich
nicht aber dennoch in der autoindustrie
läuft man natürlich sturm was bringt das
für das klima aber auch für uns
bürgerinnen und bürger darüber möchten
wir jetzt sprechen mit dem cdu
verkehrsexperten thomas bader ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet guten tag herr bareiß
es gibt daher gestern im eu-parlament
bei dieser entscheidung und schon jetzt
wird auch dagegen sturm gelaufen es muss
ja noch mit den mitgliedstaaten
abgestimmt werden dennoch die
befürchtung für viele es wird eine
entscheidung getroffen gegen die
innovation gegen er die bürger und auch
die große frage im raum wie viel bringt
das wirklich für den klimaschutz ihre
einschätzung
einen ist sehr weitreichend entscheidung
der sich sicherlich sehr effizient auch
sparsam die deutschen zu werden hier
auch wirklich weltmarktführer und
deshalb halte ich ein komplettes verbot
nächsten jahre für falsch und ich glaube
dass wir auch die nächsten jahrzehnte
auch in der weltlichen acht motoren
sehen werden auch die lkws werden
auch fahren insofern denke ich immer
dass wir hier über die technologieoffen
reingehen müssen wir brauchen auch eine
lösung für bestandsfahrzeuge das heißt
wir haben ja auch nach zwanzig und
dreißig noch viele autos auf die straße
haben brauchen das synthetische
kraftstoffe kraftstoffe die tiere zwei
freundlich sind deshalb ist dieses
verbot macht nur wenn es kurz gedacht
wir langfristig gesehen brauchen wir
auch acht stufen die einfach nur zwei
freundlich und dazu brauchen wir auch
männer was würde es bedeuten wenn es
jetzt eben dieses verbot doch geben
würde für die deutschen autokonzerne wie
vw mercedes und bmw
also ich glaube das ist ein ganz ganz
große herausforderung sein wird für die
hersteller aber auch für die zulieferer
und ich glaube dass wir auch diesen
transformationsprozessen nur so
hinbekommen auch mit den arbeitsplätzen
wenn möglich auch technologieoffen dann
gehen wir wirklich auf verschiedene
technologien möglich machen das heißt
darin auch ihre qualität verein bringen
auch mehr natürlich auch
elektrofahrzeuge auf den markt aber auch
weiterhin natürlich auch für männer
motoren zu lassen und natürlich auch ein
drittel und die wasserstoff
brennstoffzelle auch das sind sehr
spannende habe ich die technologie in
die nächsten jahren auch an bedeutung zu
gewinnen das heißt wir müssen hier offen
reingehen nicht nur verboten sondern
brauchen offenheit wie unsere chance und
auch arbeitsplätze erhält
ist man bei den e autos überhaupt
derzeit so weit dass man bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt wir sprechen vom jahr 2035 das
so aufstellen kann dass sich bürgerinnen
und bürger ist nicht darum sorgen müssen
wie komme ich sag es mal ganz platt
morgens in die arbeit das also somit der
laden läuft
ja zur arbeit einerseits aber es geht
auch darum dass man da auch noch spanien
in urlaub fahren kann italien das heißt
sie brauchen in ganz europa die
ladeinfrastruktur und ist noch in das
große thema das wir hier in nächsten
zehn jahre ganz schnell vorankommen
wahrscheinlich dass die in fraktur so
flächenmäßig aufgebaut ist dass die
menschen auch vertrauen in die
elektrofahrzeuge habe ich privat ja
schon einiges getan auch deutschland ist
hier schon sehr sehr weit auch schon in
der im aufbau aber ich habe das wirklich
auch hier aus sehen müssen dass wir dann
auch von einer riesenherausforderung
sind und wahrscheinlich werden die
fahrzeuge sogar ein zehn jahren
flächendeckend an können aber in
gaststätten
aber auch ein land noch sehr teuer
aufzubauen sagen es ist eines der großen
schule die noch kommen wird und dann
auch die frage was bringt es wirklich
fürs klima die eu hat sich hohe ziele
gesteckt allen mitgliedstaaten ist klar
man will die erfüllen was würde diese
maßnahme bringen es dass wenigstens auf
der habenseite dass man sagen muss gut
da machen wir dann auch wirklich
diesbezüglich große fortschritte
natürlich wird das thema mobilität
nächsten jahr immer weniger co2
emittieren da war ziemlich nächsten jahr
gleich wo sie forscht gegeben ich glaube
dass einfach die offenen machen müssen
weil wir wissen da ich mal nicht nur die
neue fahrzeuge 135 co2 freie stadt oder
die zwei frankenstein brauchen auch die
bestands wirken die autos die heute
verkauft werden werden auch in 10 15
jahren auf deutschen straßen fahren und
deshalb brauchen wir auch eine lösung
für die für die bestehenden ekg sind
auch im jahr 15 millionen pkws was das
ziel ist 20 30 elektrofahrzeuge haben
30 millionen autos in deutschland
einfach männer betroffen sind und die
müssen dann die biokraftstoffen oder mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen stück für
stück getankt werden so dass wir auch
hier bestand wirklich auch co2
freundlicher gestalten können vielen
dank cdu verkehrsexperte thomas bareiß
hier zum verbrenner aus mit einer
deutlichen kritik zu diesem vorschlag
danke danke schön